prudence au volant demain matin les
routes du Val de Loire devraient être de
nouveau verglacés tôt ce matin on a
recensé une dizaine d'accidents sur la
85 la 28 et l'A10 cette nuit la neige
pourrait même faire son retour alors les
salles sont de sortie exemple sur les
routes départementales du Sud Touraine
avec Allen chapelet
Damien et Sébastien font partie des 200
agents Mobilis
ables comme
de pour rendre plus sûr les 3650 km de
route départementale que compte l'indres
et Loire ce mercredi matin depuis 7h30
ils ont pour mission de salés les routes
secondaires de leur secteur ils ont pris
la suite de leurs collègues de nuit qui
sont déjà intervenus sur les axes les
plus fréquentés
on fait un circuit qui va de la
celle-saint-avant jusqu'à
Varennes pour ceux qui connaissent le
sud un petit peu et on remonte de faire
Larson dans le sud jusqu'au la ville de
Louroux ça c'est les extrémités du
secteur nous là notre centre on a été
séparés en deux on a deux véhicules qui
tournent ce matin ça permet de saler
pour ce matin pour ceux qui étaient pas
encore parti et ça va permettre aussi de
tenir un peu le gel pour demain matin si
ça redescend encore un petit peu en
température
cette année le dispositif de viabilité
hivernale est en place jusqu'au 27
février des semaines durant lesquelles à
la Direction des routes on garde un œil
attentif aux prévisions météo pour
intervenir seulement si nécessaire
quand la courbe de température bleue
rejoint la courbe de température de
point de rosée on sait qu'il y a un
risque ici de glissant cette formation
de verglas sur les routes on a 14 salles
qui sont répartis sur l'ensemble de nos
sta service territoriaux d'aménagement
qui ont des centres d'où partent nos
salles pour
minimiser au maximum le temps de salage
on sait parce que c'est quand même de la
pollution donc on essaye de le faire
vraiment à très bon escient et de pas en
mettre plus qu'il n'en faudrait un
risque de verglight à nouveau possible
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi il y a
donc fort à parier que les salles seront
à nouveau de sortie